j'ai fait une demande d'adoption à la
DAF à 23 ans pour pouvoir avoir un
enfant adoptif aujourd'hui l'enfant est
arrivé chez moi il se trouve qu'il a 10
ans de plus que moi pas son temps avec
ses copains je vais au baby-foot je suis
son père il a beau être plus âgée que
moi c'est mon fils j'en ai un
responsabilité qu'est-ce que vous
pourriez dire à cet enfant en tant que
femme qui pourrait lui expliquer qui
pourrait le convaincre de poursuivre ses
études mais c'est très important les
études et instant à l'heure actuelle on
a besoin de travailler de vraiment c'est
très très important je suis pas contre
qui se désaltère contre son stuff mais
la bière la bière non mais
demander s'il vous plaît
expliquer ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que c'est une dame